hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys versus
heute gibt eine pavlova torte und zwar
ist es eine beige torte also der teig
das ist ein baiser teig dann kommt eine
sandschicht rein und das ganze wird dann
noch getoppt mit früchten und so werde
ich das heute auf ja so auf schwarz
werde da art machen also mit kirschen
und mit etwas tat bitter schokolade und
zuerst muss man jetzt diesen hannover
teig herstellen
dann müsst ihr euch an ein bisschen zeit
mitnehmen denn da muss im ofen etwas
austrocknen und das dauert eine weile
aber man kann das zum beispiel auch am
vortag zubereiten und am nächsten tag
dann einfach die torte fertigstellen und
da vorne stehen zumal die zutaten
ich brauch sechs eiweiße eine ps als 300
gramm zucker 50 gramm
zartbitterschokolade einen teelöffel
speisestärke und etwas von extrakt und
so erst nehmen die jetzt das eiweiß bzw
die eiweiße und gibt es jetzt in eine
rührschüssel die sollte fettfrei sein
das heißt da darf auch jetzt da dürfen
uns keine rückstände vom eigelb drin
sein
ich will mein gewissen fett drin dann
kommt die prise salz mit dazu das
zerstört die arbeitsstruktur etwas
schneller
und jetzt werde ich das einfach mal
steigt
sobald es als steif ist gibt er den
zucker mit rein
ganz langsam am rand entlang und dann
wird es noch mal so etwa fünf minuten
gerührt dann löst sich der zucker auch
und die masse wird richtig stabil
das mache ich gleich auf höchste stufe
aber in der zwischenzeit werde ich jetzt
hier schon mal die schokolade schmelzen
und zwar mache ich das jetzt einfach in
so einer kleinen tüte
sie verschließen
jetzt nämlich einfach moratti kam habe
ich nämlich schon heißes wasser drin
habe es kurz aufkochen lassen wieder
ausgestellt und hinter ist einfach die
schokolade rheinisches nicht doch das
ist jetzt mein voller ernst denn dadurch
speichern
dafür ist eine teekanne gut
sie steht ja geht den ganzen tag auf dem
herd deswegen für irgendwas muss sehr
gut sein
und die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt
auch habt ihr zwei backpapier töten und
den ofen habe ich bereits auf 210 grad
umluft gestellt aber wenig ein um lust
habt könnt ihr auch 230 grad ober
unterhitze stellen letztlich den bug
geboren oben und neben den bug rahmen
der 20 zentimeter im durchmesser
aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch einen
teller oder im deckel benutzen da
einfach diese größe hat was sollt nicht
verrutschen und dann zeichne ich hier
dieser kreis vor und drehte spaß mit ihr
aber dann wieder um und jetzt lasse ich
kurz diese masse noch fünf minuten
rühren und dann bin ich gleich so weit
so sollte die masse aussehen also schön
glänzend und jetzt nehme ich hier die
reste noch herunter wusstest du dass die
papierakte in neuseeland und australien
ein nationalgericht also australien
wusste ich mir dann ich mir aber nie
streiten sich darum erfunden hat ich
glaube das musste ich sogar mal ich
glaube bei meinem alten per rezept hatte
ich das sogar mal erwähnt aber dass sie
schon mal vergessen aber jetzt gut aus
sagt der name pavel novak kommt mir
allerdings ein bisschen spanisch vor
jetzt ist die schokolade auch
geschmolzen und dies jetzt auch nicht so
heiß also dies leicht abgekühlt jetzt
kenne ich sie mit dazu geben die jetzt
halt ganz besonders gut weil sie aus dem
rat teekanne stammt
und jetzt gebe ich auch noch direkt die
speisestärke mit dazu und das vanille
extrakt und jetzt 80 beim unterheben
einfach nur drauf dass ich nicht alles
zusammen vermenge sondern dass so ein
bisschen sind marita effekt noch dabei
übrig bleibt wenn das panel extrakt
nichts hat kaum noch kommen lassen uns
einfach weglassen
aber es gibt halt doch mal ein schönes
aroma gemeinsam zu schokolade
jetzt kann ich direkt diese masse auf
beide backpapier legen verteilen die
kreise sieht man übrigens besser wenn
man das ganze auf eine helle unterlage
stand
also bitte liebe ich total das sieht
immer so locker leicht aus ich liebe
diese musik ist es auch kein problem
oder ist kein problem man muss halt nur
ein paar minuten rühren und steht dann
halt da aber geht auf jeden fall auch
für dieses rezept braucht man in brand
gerät oder die küchenmaschine
missbrauchen auch jedenfalls definitiv
also mit der hand dass ein bisschen zwei
abschnitte damit man glaube ich eine
stunde lang rühren und wer immer noch
nicht fertig mit wird die maß genug
verstrichen das mache ich am liebsten
mit einer palette und zwar solltet ihr
einfach einen schönen runden tortenboden
hinbekommen es geht am besten wenn ihr
einfach oben etwas flach drückt müssen
wir darauf achten dass jetzt nicht zu
viel dran rum spielt damit diese mama
optik noch erhalten bleibt und dann
mache ich erstmal die oberfläche immer
so gleichmäßig und streicht dann am rand
noch mal entlang
warum machte sich im bug ram uns weist
bei pablo was das muss jetzt alles gut
von außen trocknen
deswegen mag ich das jetzt auch bei
umluft und damit er eben überall genug
luft dran kommt und ich keine handhabe
back ich das eben ohne back haben
das ist kein programm kein bug zu
gbagbos so genau also im prinzip recht
gar nicht viel werkzeug für diese torte
des schicken ist sehr einfach dort ohne
richtig leckere lockere tor
so jetzt hab ich das alles gut
verstrichen beim letzten mal hatte ich
übrigens 220 er böden auf ein paar köpfe
bekommen also vom platz erreicht aber im
backofen gehen die noch ein bisschen
auseinander deswegen ist es besser wenn
ihr die auf zwei verschiedenen
backpapier mögen was jetzt kann ich
beide böden in einem backofen backen
muss jetzt aber von 210 auf 110 grad
zurück schalten dann bekommen die b&c
ein bisschen farbe und dann trocknen sie
aber nur noch und falls ihr mit ober
unterhitze bugs müsst ihr einfach von
230 auf 130 zu schalten
und soweit es im ofen für 60 minuten
gebacken
nachdem nach dieser backzeit stelle ich
den ofen ab und lass es einfach komplett
im ofen ab könnten wenn sie dann
komplett kalt sind geht es gleich weiter
di padova sind jetzt gebacken und
bereits abgekühlt und von der konsistenz
hettich sind außen sehr schön trocken
und innen aber noch feucht also wieso
marshmallow irgendwie und ähnelt und
haben wir das dieses vanille extrakt und
das mit wirklich sehr gut und diese
schokolade noch also ein sieg perfekt
und das möchte ich jetzt schicht mit
etwas sahne und kirschen und zeige mich
vorne mal kurz die zutaten an zutaten
brauche ich ein glas schattenmorellen
oder sauerkirschen 600 gramm sahne sechs
teelöffel seiner fahrt etwas zarter
schokolade und 100 gramm gehobelte
mandeln die schattenmorellen die habe
ich jetzt bereits ab gegossen und den
saft aufgefangen und zwar kommt der in
einen kleinen topf und da wir jetzt
vergessen sie zwei esslöffel zucker zu
stellen
jetzt gebe ich da noch zwei esslöffel
zucker mit rein einig einen so und dann
wird er sagt erst mal aufgekocht und
muss dann so lange kochen bis a 1
reduziert ist also bisher so eine art
sirup haben hatte zwei esslöffel reichen
schon du darfst männer und das mache ich
jetzt kurz und macht dann mit den
restlichen zutaten weiter
der sirup ist jetzt reduziert und ich
hatte die zwischenzeit genutzt um die
kleine ella zu stellen und leiter ist
ein unfall passiert und ich musste mein
oberteil wechseln falls ihr euch jetzt
vielleicht fragt warum ich jetzt was
anderes was hat so also sieht der sirup
jetzt aus richtig schön dickflüssig und
die farbe ist wirklich richtig genial
ganz ganz toll hier drüben habe ich
jetzt bereits in der pfanne erwärmt und
da werde ich jetzt die mandel blätter
hineingeben
sie bekommen dann ein bisschen farbe es
gab so viele brauchen jetzt doch nicht
ich denke doch nur die hälfte und ich
kann jetzt schon mal die sahne schlagen
die hatte ich in der zwischenzeit aber
noch mal kühl gestellt also da musste
immer aufpassen dass sie da nicht mehr
ganz kalt ist gebe ich jetzt hier in die
röhre schritte und schlagt sie kurz an
und dann kommen da sechs telefonat mit
dazu und dann schlage ich sie steigt
also dieser habe ich jetzt geschlagen
dann ist natürlich aufpassen dass ihr
sie nicht zuschlägt
die spiel letztendlich jetzt gebe ich
die da drauf die hälfte
darüber gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen was
von dem sirup dann ist das sehr
aufpassen wer ist sehr heiß für mich gab
schon verbrannt
natürlich dann die hälfte der dann hat
mit
und ein paar mandeln blätter
jetzt kommt die seite gibt's obendrauf
deshalb ein bisschen lockerer also da
muss man ein bisschen aufpassen
dann die zweite geschichte
da müsste jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtig
arbeiten mit der sahne sind bisschen den
bc vest strecken und dann wiederholt
sich das ganze einfach noch mal
und bevor ich die torte anschneiden
stelle ich hier nochmal in den
kühlschrank für etwa eine halbe stunde
und dann können wir sie direkt an
schneiden die torte ist jetzt fertig
gekühlt und jetzt mache ich noch ein
paar schoko späne als eigentlich sowieso
schon perfekt aus aber komm ich wollte
dazu machen also mache ich das jetzt
auch also die sind echt genial aus ich
glaube auch nicht schlecht also mein
klassenlehrer demo zu murat des messe
vom körper weg
ich habe das geht halt net das muss man
jetzt so an die hüfte so ein bisschen
und dann einfach abschaffen
jetzt kann ich die torte direkt
anschneiden morath weise dir so gut
gefällt die stadt auch zum schneiden
also es geht wirklich super einfach denn
der pc sei ganz locker und leicht wie
sie trocken sind sehr sehr gefährlich
weil weil dies die schmecken wird nicht
so locker und leicht ist wirklich ganz
allein die ganze torte essen nimmst aber
richtig viel zu probieren
aber er schmeckt herrlich identisch
schmeckt ist genial
also ganz ganz gefährlich hast du noch
mal drei vier stücke gerissen ich
probiere jetzt ja erst mal dass kein
besitztum liegt also in der sahne habe
ich ja keinen zucker mit dabei und zwar
deswegen weil er der pc schon süß genug
ist und dann habe ich ja noch diesen
sirup drauf der sehr sauer schmeckt aber
wirklich also das ganze müsste jetzt
eigentlich rundum wirklich gut drücken
sollten sich alle komponenten oder
gänzlich also noch einen drauf typische
mit gigantisch es war wirklich war
kann es sein dass du hast du café ein
immer näher
ich wollte eigentlich aber da du mir
keine nespresso gemacht habe ich gedacht
kommen dass ich ihn einfach weg
aber man könnte natürlich noch zu fügen
und man kann zum beispiel auch wenn man
so ein bisschen schwarzwälder art möchte
kann auch noch bis vier schweizer mit zu
dem sirup geben gibt dem ganzen dann
nochmal einen besonders für die so wie
es ist ist wie ich ging also ich finds
auch so richtig gut vor allem auch
optisch und dann kann schon wirklich war
ihr nicht du spinnst karamellsoße würden
so frau werner kammer war es besser
gebrauchen wenn man keine kirschen mag
kann man sie natürlich auch austauschen
man kann zum beispiel auch frische
beeren nehmen sobald die bären saison
beginnt und man kann den kuchen gut
vorbereiten das hatte ich auch schon
gesagt dass man diese bc bereits am
vortag machen kann und am tag des
lavierens würde ich dann erste torte
zusammensetzen
also ich würde jetzt wirklich noch am
gleichen tag verzehrt und jetzt nicht
noch über nacht lagern
ja und wenn ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt geht auch tennis - blog.de da
steht noch mal ganz genau und wir teilen
die jetzt mit man kann auch die ganze
klasse und dünneren jedoch
es zeigt uns seine morath wie das geht
genau nämlich konnte alles ganz genau
jetzt will ich ganz viel spaß von
nachfragten und wir sehen uns das
nächste mal mache ich das immer